now these aren't your average EQ as soon
as look at you African crocodiles here
these are crocodiles spinning in a
feeding frenzy tearing apart an antelope
they're busy to say the least with a big
job to do enter a hippo our hippo
inexplicably starts to lick the bodies
of the feeding crocodiles scientists
haven't figured out why yet but hippos
seem to enjoy hanging with these
bloodthirsty killers as they shred their
victim and gorge on its flesh talk about
insolence why do the Crocs put up
winners well first of all the hippos are
no threat they're vegetarian secondly
the hippos are more powerful than the
Crocs so the Crocs carry on as if the
hippos aren't even there and if you
think this is boring
here's a baby hippo wading into a bevy
of crocodiles you know it must be
genetic the baby hippo immediately
starts gnawing on the spines of the
Crocs back now this has got to be
annoying but well what are they gonna do
answer nothing you want to know how
hippos feel about the so called
danger of getting too close to a
crocodile yeah I guess that about sums
it up